foreign
weekend was the weekend exactly seven
days prior to November 13th was parents
weekend the fall and the fall
and we had an amazing weekend together
and we drove out of town that Sunday
morning so it would have been November
6th
and we always left early on Sunday
morning because there was we would have
waited all afternoon to see the kids
and we literally high-fived each other
that day
we literally congratulated each other we
were like we've done it
we've done it we have created their
adulting their kind
we've got a
we can rest easy and
Stacy and I were planning on
taking a lot of trips and spent a lot of
time on the road and
and just in a week yeah it all changed
we're learning new details about the
night four college students were
murdered near the University of Idaho
campus officials spoke with the public
for the first time saying they think
this attack was targeted we're also
learning more about one of those victims
Ethan Chapin
[Music]
we spent a lot of time together
after the two months two months together
we spent we just walked it out
talked
told stories
cried one day I was out walking by
myself
I was crying so hard I just it was just
whatever and this I happened upon
somebody and I thought they were gonna
call 9-1-1 on me but I'm just like it's
okay I just
having a moment
going back to this weekend
yeah they we went to the alumni offices
and there was a bunch of people there
and they honored us with
[Music]
um honorary University of Idaho degrees
so it's cute we're official we're
official Idaho alumni the next Milestone
is going to be Mother's Day
uh
that's going to be a tough day
Ethan loved Morgan Wallen
and it was Mother's Day a year ago and
it was like the week before that Morgan
Wallen leaked on his social media that
he'd written a song for his mom on for
Mother's Day to be released on Mother's
Day
and Ethan I couldn't I as quickly as it
ran on my social media Ethan had sent
that to me and was like I am so excited
for this song for Mother's Day and I
woke up Mother's Day morning and he'd
sent me the the whatever the link to the
whole song is the sweetest and it will
now always forever be my
most favorite song but it was very cute
it's people like that that you wish you
could be like hey Morgan Paul and you
let me tell you how much you've touched
our life by that
she was so excited to send me that song
on that day
we we did everything as a family
from the time we got up to the time we
went to bed
and uh
I don't know it's just all you just got
to spend time with your kids and love on
them and
do a lot of fun stuff and because they
grow up so fast
man we're so blessed to have had that
time
I can honestly say I don't think we
could spend more time with our kids and
our family and and as because of that we
have we don't have that regret
I mean I don't think we missed a
basketball game or a sporting event of
our kids and I can remember one weekend
there was probably 18.
sporting events between Macy's club
soccer and the two boys playing
basketball and we hit them all or we
would divide and conquer and then meet
at the next one
I wouldn't know what I know now and go
and change the 20 years we had
you know when it's gonna just life is
gonna throw you a curveball I mean I
think we got the worst curveball
[Music]